kate and john gosselin are at war once
again she is accusing her ex of being
quote
violent and abusive after an incident
with their 16 year old son colin
now john has come to e.t to give his
side of the story and
john right off the bat i have to ask you
what is your reaction to kate's claims
i just keep on having to defend myself
all the time and
it's getting really old i just find it
very unfair that
my private life with my children
is being blasted out by someone who
wasn't even there
john i want to read you this quote from
kate because she said
the police need to do their jobs i'm so
sick of john's abuse being disguised as
everything but
i don't want my children around him
enough is enough
oh that's a very interesting quote
because i believe in the police force is
doing their jobs
um they investigated i talked to both
officers detective
it was an argument that escalated into
something um
you know i had to restrain him and i've
done it a couple times
i didn't think he would call the police
but he wanted to get his way and
did their investigation and there's no
charges or
citations filed in fact today john
shared this letter with e.t
it's from a state caseworker and it says
an investigation found the abuse report
unfounded i find it interesting that
kate is actually talking about hannah
and colin considering that i have sole
legal and
physical custody of colin i've gone to
all his therapy sessions
and kate hasn't talked to him in five
years i mean kate didn't even show up
for his
custody battle when they awarded me sole
legal and physical custody
so now i find it interesting that she's
so concerned about a child she doesn't
even talk to
john a former dj and reality star now
works as an
i.t director at a hospital he says his
son colin regrets the abuse claim
which he made on instagram in a post
that has since been deleted
i have nothing to hide i'm out here on
et doing an interview in the middle of
my lunch break at word
john just so everybody understands colin
spent two years in a special needs
program
he was placed there against his will and
was misdiagnosed
his main disability is ptsd which is
stemmed from the abuse of his mother
so are you saying kate has been abusive
to colin in the past
uh yes i have the evidence to prove that
and
you know she better watch what she's
saying kate has denied abusing colin
calling the claims absolutely unfounded
what do you think her motives are
i think her motives are fame money and
those who have always been her motives
and getting herself back on tv
i'm dating again finally kate's last
reality show
kate plus date it was canceled last year
john do you have a message for kate
kate the message to you is to stop
unless you don't want to have any out of
any relationship with your children in
the future
you're ruining that it's not about me
it's about how they have to live their
life
by you making false accusations about
things that never occurred